l'afghanistan est un pays qui est en
guerre depuis plusieurs décennies
quand j'étais coach
[Musique]
beghal jeunes conducteurs en moyenne
toujours on se contente les médecins
restent en permanence au chevet des
enfants
on a eu beaucoup d'enfants tués par les
bombardements et on est très
certainement un conflit qui a fait
plusieurs centaines de milliers de mains
10h10
moi ce que je veux être honnête 8 heures
pauses musicales marconnet n'a comic
books and i'm bad bernard spitz all
things digital
je vous emmène dans un pays en plein
chaos et je vais vous expliquer pourquoi
malheureusement ça risque de durer
[Musique]
ok ok go au mois de septembre 2019 je
suis parti pour brut en afghanistan avec
le vidéaste les eaux grasses et de la
chaîne youtube de retirer ology on s'est
rendus là-bas pour vous montrer comment
la guerre impact le quotidien des civils
et pendant notre mission il ya eu
plusieurs attentats on est d'abord allé
à kandahar une ville particulièrement
instable au sud du pays pour rencontrer
wali un médecin du comité international
de la croix rouge qui soignent des
blessés de guerre depuis plus de 15 ans
à
raté la mine au chili ce monde entier
suite
m
[Musique]
dès 6 heures de bois les jo auront des
rôles au meeting de gbagbo
sort
et pas qu'un peu des enfants blessés
comme le petit arabe wali il y en a des
dizaines de milliers en afghanistan et
malheureusement ça fait un moment que ça
dure parce que le pays est en guerre
depuis plus de 40 ans
[Musique]
là avec les on en arrivait dans le
département de malnutrition il ya 37
enfants qui sont pris en charge
et en sous poids certain sens même en
urgence
[Musique]
ici les enfants sont vraiment très
fragile au départ ce sont des
nourrissons ils ont
donc il ya tout le temps tout le temps
des médecins pour les surveiller 24
heures sur 24
s'assurer qu'ils vont bien
[Musique]
2 kg et ils mentent at least vu
l'horreur fluctue de borny je suis aussi
des rips marcel ce rythme il est ma
seule chine au stade
[Musique]
la plupart des enfants qui souffrent de
malnutrition et qui arrivent à l'hôpital
qui sont pris en charge médicalement de
très grandes chances
tiens les maladies qui pourraient
aggraver la situation de malnutrition
comme des diarrhées fièvre sont
immédiatement traité est en fuite une
fois qu'ils sont stabilisés les médecins
dans nos bébés un les riches en
nutriments qui leur permet de retrouver
rapidement une croissance normale
[Musique]
c'est fini
hi fi n'a pu trouver des mots
votre look and feel that et leur buteur
de situation intéressante
historiquement l'afghanistan a d'abord
été envahie par l'union soviétique à la
fin des années 70 une guerre qui va
durer pendant dix ans jusqu'en 1989 et
avant l'intervention américaine
à partir de 2001 il ya eu la prise de
pouvoir d'un groupe armé appelé les
talibans
sept allemands sont un concours
islamistes rigoriste sur le plan moral
avec une vision inspirée de l'islam
politique qui prennent le pouvoir en
1996 il met en place un régime qui va
durer jusqu'en 2001 il accueille pendant
cette période
un groupe armé internationale appelée al
qaïda responsables en septembre 2001 des
attentats sur les tours jumelles à new
york
à partir de là les états unis prennent
la décision avec un mandat des nations
unies d'intervenir dans le pays en
octobre 2001 le régime taliban et
renversé et remplacé par un nouveau
régime qui s'installe à partir de 2002
jusqu'à la situation actuelle avec un
affrontement très violent entre le
régime issu de l'intervention à kaboul
et l'insurrection talibane de l'autre
côté
nos jours
moscou
celui liant
oui les soldes ça soit la police
saleh
c'est notre intérêt
ça fait là
et c'est ça en fait qui est incroyable
les ennemis se retrouve dans le même
hôpital pour être soigné il ya donc ici
des soldats de l'armée afghane et des
talibans ou en tout cas des soutiens des
talibans l'un d'eux a accepté de nous
parler
écoutez bien son discours parce que ça
permet de comprendre la situation
actuelle en afghanistan
[Musique]
la manière dont les militaires
américains ont agi notamment au début
des années 2000 a provoqué une
indignation chez les afghans il faut
bien comprendre que dans les premières
années en raison des attentats du 11
septembre les militaires américains
reçoivent carte blanche en particulier
les forces spéciales américaines qui
avaient pour mission de traquer et de
tuer les militants d'al qaïda et les
militants talibans ils ont mis en place
des milices dans tout le pays qui ont
torturé des gens en les suspectant
d'être talibans mais beaucoup d'image de
ses actes de torture en montrant la
violence et des exactions des forces
spéciales américaines ont fuité sur les
réseaux sociaux notamment cette vidéo
elle a été révélée en 2013 par le
journaliste d'investigation américain
matthew wilkins
à l'époque la cour pénale internationale
avait même essayé de lancer une
procédure d' enquête contre les crimes
de guerre commis en afghanistan mais
elle n'avait finalement pas abouti dont
beaucoup de gens ont été tués ou
torturés
sans avoir jamais participé au mouvement
taliban sans jamais avoir été dans al
qaïda au bout de quelques années le
rejet des états unis est devenue très
fort très très fort darul islam de plus
m
en fait il est impossible de comprendre
les talibans et la situation afghane
si on omet comme on le fait trop souvent
le fait que c'est une société qui a
passé 40 ans dans la guerre civile
c'est une société dont 80% de la
population est menée dans la guerre la
popularité des talibans dans les
campagnes elle s'explique par leur
capacité à exercer le droit à mettre en
place des tribunaux dont les décisions
sont respectées d'un côté leurs juges
sont reconnus comme des juges islamique
qui sont reconnus comme des gens dont
les décisions s'inspire des textes
islamiques et leur deuxième avantage
c'est le fait que leurs décisions sont
respectés que les gens ont peur de
désobéir car les punitions pour ceux qui
désobéissent au jugement aliments
extrêmement sévère les gens sont bannis
les maisons souvent détruits de voir les
gens sont tués
cette capacité pour les talibans de
dissuader toute forme de désobéissance
elle est en fait un des fondements de
leur popularité
il contrôle tout la voiture s'il ya pas
d explosifs
une belle vie
ou pas de kandahar pour aller à kaboul
avec un avion du cicr
[Musique]
kaboul est devenue une des villes les
plus dangereuses au monde
c'est une mégapole de cinq millions
d'habitants où toutes les modalités de
vie sont sont imprégnés de la guerre
[Musique]
mais quel rôle
les attentats sont monnaie courante ils
sont devenus extrêmement fréquents et
énormément d'afghans qui ont perdu un de
leurs proches voire plusieurs voire
parfois des familles balayée par les
attentats parce qu'il passait au mauvais
moment au mauvais endroit
du côté du jour
vergne
nous
la guerre est partout on a des blocs de
béton qui sont en fait des blogs qu'on
appelle anti blast qui servent à
empêcher les attentats qui sont posées
un peu partout de nombreuses rues sont
fermées un tout le centre ville en fête
est fermée pour laisser sa place aux
bases occidentales aux ambassades
occidentales
arrivée plusieurs attentats dont deux
qui se sont produits à kaboul et qui ont
fait des dizaines de morts donc la
situation est extrêmement tendue les
principales cibles à chaque fois sont
souvent les militaires et parfois quand
on a le temps de discuter avec eux nous
laisse un peu filmés
en fait on se fait accompagner par un
policier qui nous escortent simplement
parce que
contexte sécuritaire assez
piqué ça on
tournant pour des cibles louis-do ashot
[Musique]
m
je suis
juste à l'ordre public
le contexte est vraiment tendu en
samedi
ça c'est qu'on ne peut pas qui mais les
checkpoints
son trait c'est
donc là on est en finale
complexe et à rien
[Musique]
c'est dans ce contexte extrêmement tendu
qu'on est allé à la rencontre d'un
médecin exceptionnel il s'appelle
alberto cairo et il s'occupe d'un centre
de rééducation où les victimes de la
guerre peuvent se reconstruire grâce au
sport et aux étudiants
taper des familles
on allait concentrer
chacun
[Applaudissements]
m
ce équipe féminine de basket par feu
roulant de kaboul ils sont au taquet
pour l'instant à s'entraîne son encontre
et chauffée
impressionnant
en quatre matches et un doctorat
hydrique d'un gilet basculement dans les
bars et mocassins qui devra le religieux
body'minute du zoo aziz gul mohammed
avec micro et une chanteuse en herbe en
ce temps de crise dans sa rue d'avron
est encore méconnu valriche me canadas
meyrannes immobiliers afghanistan ne
savent pas reconnaître et actiris à mi
mandat d'attirer bon se leva thierry
poupard a comme stendhal chambre
y à coeur joie au one order new york est
en mal d'arguments faute sur 24 à madrid
qu'il kim chi town oistamo et
d'annemasse tout le match
m
mais on propose de jouer avec elle au
basket je vais m'installer sur un
fauteuil et puis je vais tenter de jouer
avec elle je pense que je vais galérer
ils m'ont attaché complètement pour que
je pense que c'est vraiment que je fasse
corps avec le fauteuil
[Applaudissements]
qui
[Musique]
non
m
pour
oui
chaud
[Applaudissements]
pour la forme c'est bidon
ouais
on va te suis hyper impressionné par les
filles sont vraiment
pendant la compétition et tout énoncé
renverser un moment des soldes désirait
vraiment est souvent leur enfin un truc
à son détermination 100% et
ils sont tous pour gagner et te mettre
une grosse trace bricole
28 secondes
tout à fait
gibbs m des confidences de veille
oups
[Musique]
m